it has been a long time since I've been
this disgusted with those voters who
insisted that there was no difference
between Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton
I'm always disgusted with the Trump
voters that's that's a mainstay that's
nothing new
but there were people people on the Left
ostensibly who said in practical terms
there's just no difference between Trump
and Hillary a vote for Trump a vote for
Hillary it's all the same because
whichever one of them wins it doesn't
really make a difference in our lives
for our children for our grandchildren
they are both representatives of
maintaining the Toxic status quo of
corporatism and vulture capitalism and
so on and so forth there was even a
movement a movement called Bernie or
bust where lots of people felt this way
Trump and Hillary were both tools of the
corporate political status quo and if
it's not going to be Bernie it doesn't
matter some of them didn't vote some of
them voted third-party some of them
voted for Trump as a sort of protest
vote that idea and I'm not going after
the Bernie er Buster's specifically here
but the idea that there is no practical
consequence to Hillary versus Trump has
blown up in our faces yet again as
Donald Trump is going to get to select
another Supreme Court justice because
Anthony Kennedy is going to retire and
is going to now by virtue of this Trump
will be able to influence the future of
the United States for at least a
generation including possibly the repeal
of roe v wade but Trump and Hillary were
going to be the same it didn't matter
which of them won I told you earlier in
the week that the Supreme Court punted
on a couple of key decisions one
involving an anti-gay florist in
Washington State another involving
believe it was redistricting in Texas
and I mentioned you know Anthony Kennedy
is going to turn 82 very soon courts
will sometimes the Supreme Court will
sometimes four go big precedent setting
decisions when there's a justice that's
close to retirement and exactly as
alluded to Anthony Kennedy has announced
he's going to step down from the court
at the end of July and everything that
any
sensible progressive holds dear that the
court has influence on is on the table
at this point this is no longer
replacing a conservative justice with
another conservative justice this is
taking a moderate vote
Anthony Kennedy a Justice who voted for
same-sex marriage who has voted for
access to abortions for affirmative
action he is out and he is going to be
replaced with a vile conservative
ideologue the reason we know that is
because that's what Donald Trump said
Donald Trump said before he was even
elected what his philosophy would be for
appointing justices to the Supreme Court
and once Trump selects one of those
conservative justices from whatever list
he's working off of at this point it
will be one of the most massively
pro-corporate Supreme Court's in history
could be the end of roe v wade could be
the end to the federal right to abortion
and you will see many states ban
abortion altogether Jeffrey Toobin has
talked about this I don't think we're
gonna get to it today but maybe tomorrow
we can talk about that and once this
happens you're talking about a return to
the dark ages and I think it is really
important not to be hyperbolic we are
very careful Pat to not make analogies
to Nazism when there is not really an
analogy to be made it's important to say
to not say this is the worst it's ever
been if that's not actually true we
don't want to be hyperbolic but what we
are seeing here is a decided move
backwards away from the tenets of modern
Western democracies and Donald Trump's
selection of an extreme lunatic
religious right ideal likely religious
right ideologue is going to be part of
that yeah this is really bad instead of
having four liberal justices and four
conservative justice with a moderate in
the middle yeah now you're gonna have a
five to four conservative stronghold the
only thing worse I think is if you know
Ruth Bader Ginsburg or Stephen Breyer or
to retire or I'll go I want to be morbid
but yet I I think that would be the only
thing that would you know surpass this
right what will surpass how bad this is
is when Trump gets a third pick right
that's basically what the silver lining
is there's more damage to be done and
the
primary blame for this is actual Trump
supporters but behind them are the
people who didn't think there was enough
of a difference between Trump and
Hillary to justify getting out to the
polls in November of 2016 and unless the
Senate flips in November and unless we
get Trump out in 2020 unless the next
democratic administration whenever it
happens we don't know when that'll be
puts together a serious and concerted
court packing plan the right has
co-opted to the Supreme Court
potentially for decades the untold
damage that Donald Trump is gonna do to
this country beyond his own life right
like now Donald Trump is setting in
stone damage to the United States of
America
that will extend beyond his own lifetime
I hope that the Democrats in the Senate
are ready to put up a fight I don't know
if they are I wonder whether Supreme
Court justice Jeanine Pirro come forth
come I honestly I know it sounds
absolutely ridiculous I know Jeanine
Pirro wasn't on the Heritage Foundation
list of approved names for Trump but I
would not at this point put it past him
to consider not literally Jeanine Pirro
but something as ludicrous and
cartoonish he floated the idea of
putting Judge Napolitano on the Supreme
Court and he's another Fox News guy so
it's not outside of the realm of
possibility and if you're waiting for
Democrats to grow a backbone on this
I'll remind you that they may not and
even if they did they may not be able to
do anything because Neil Gorsuch is only
on the court because Republicans refused
to hold hearings for Merrick garland
during President Obama's last term in
office they said well we're only a year
from the presidential election we want
the voters to have a say before we make
hugely significant consequential
decisions about the Supreme Court and
the Republicans won and Democrats I
believe need to play hardball there are
just a few months left until the midterm
elections why would we have confirmation
hearings for a Supreme Court justice
when in a few months
Democrats could take over the House and
Senate and completely change the caliber
and tone of American politics for the
two years that will follow I employ
for Democrats to say and do anything
they can to prevent this from going
forward before the midterms because if
you replace Anthony Kennedy with a
hardcore conservative you know what
happens John Roberts becomes your swing
vote John Roberts is no moderate and he
becomes the swing vote when you replace
Anthony Kennedy with an extraordinarily
ideological right-wing conservative what
do Dems do hate to warn you but most
likely the next to retire is going to be
Ruth Bader Ginsburg then you're talking
about an even bigger conservative
majority and elections matter whether
you're a Bernie or buster or a Trump and
Hillary are the same or my vote doesn't
matter so I don't vote whatever right
you are a part of the problem in
addition to of course the massive
problem of 60 plus million people voting
for Donald Trump which is the primary
problem you're the root of the problem
if you're at rumpus you didn't help if
you thought Trump and Hillary would have
been the same and I've been debating
whether or not to talk about this Pat we
talked about it a little bit in the
studio yesterday I've never been one of
these people who says I'll move to
Canada um partially because I know it's
hard to move to Canada but whatever the
proverbial I'll move to Canada the
authoritarian slide the attacks on press
freedom what we are going to see as
out-and-out abortion bans in many states
after Trump makes this change on the
Supreme Court I've started to think
about what options I have yeah and at
least you have some options right you go
to Israel go to Argentina maybe I've
been Poland I don't have any of those
you're lucky in that yeah if anybody can
help Pat with a place to go if anybody
can offer Pat a passport somewhere so
that he would have an option please
write in and let me know it's gonna get
really really bad in the United States